SPEAKER 1: Hey, everybody.
We are back with the marketing
manager of EatandRun.
So we got to go over this again.
EatandRun-- it's an app
that does, what now?
SPEAKER 2: Well, what
our developers have done
is design a data-driven dynamic
dining discovery and delivery
service specializing in
serving, specifically,
customers and clients
currently doing cardio.
Our primary purpose is to pair
people with the perfect place
to provide them a quick
bite, day or night,
before they're done with
their run, all from the Cloud.
SPEAKER 1: Ah, OK.
I see.
So your app delivers
food to runners.
SPEAKER 2: Yeah, exactly,
but from the Cloud.
MAX SALTONSTALL: OK,
so that interview
has 1.8 million views.
Now traffic is going
through the roof.
I'm prouder than ever to
have started this together.
But all this attention is also
going to mean some challenges
for our technology.
Right?
BUKOLA AYODELE:
Yeah, that's good.
And now more people
around the world
can grab food while jogging,
walking, or marathon training
in these uncertain times.
We should definitely make
sure our infrastructure can
handle the surge of traffic.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Sure, sure.
Everything will be fine.
We always planned for scale.
Walk, then run,
then eat and run.
Right?
BUKOLA AYODELE: Mm,
yes, of course, we did.
At totally big scale.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Oh, I see.
So maybe we're not as
ready as I thought.
Well, for the good
of the company,
for the good of the
people of the world
and their ability to
satisfy cravings on the go,
we have to figure out
a way to scale up.
BUKOLA AYODELE: Don't worry.
We're running on the
most scalable cloud
architecture in the world.
And I'm sure that
we have the capacity
to handle any traffic spikes.
They deal with enormous
denial of service attacks
before breakfast.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Breakfast, yes.
OK, but let's do some research.
This article on the internet
has suggested some changes
that I think we can make.
MAX SALTONSTALL: OK, one
option is load balancers
and managed instance groups.
With all this traffic,
we could deploy
load balancers to distribute
load more efficiently
across our front end servers.
Then on top of that, we set
up managed instance groups
for our virtual machine.
So each group can scale up
or resize based on demand.
MAX SALTONSTALL: And option
two looks like Cloud CDN.
We could speed up the delivery
of our assets to our clients
with a content delivery
network and added caching.
Looks like using Cloud CDN helps
us put the static assets closer
to those who need them, reducing
the need for those requests
to hit our compute back ends.
Then we could add caching
for static content stored
on the CDN.
So our sign-up page for
new eaters and runners
would probably load faster.
BUKOLA AYODELE: It's up to you.
What should we prioritize
for the engineering team
first since we only have limited
time and resources to handle
this big traffic spike?
Option one-- load balancers
and managed instance groups
to scale up our back serving.
Option two-- content
delivery network
and caching to speed
up our asset delivery.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
So what will it be?
[MUSIC PLAYING]